[Music]
hey guys I think today I'm gonna be
testing out five celebrity grilled
cheese recipes to find out which one is
actually the best on today's lineup we
have Martha Stewart Chrissy Teigen the
game
auntie parofsky and Kylie Jenner I
measured out all the ingredients exactly
as the recipe stated and since I'm home
alone I will also be acting as taste
texture and I will be as fair and as
impartial as a costly penny so which
celebrity has the best grilled cheese
let's find out okay so first up we have
Martha Stewart she spreads on a generous
amount of butter to each slice of white
bread making sure that it's evenly
coated and then on the other side she
spreads on some fig jam again making
sure that everything is covered and then
she puts on some Gruyere cheese as well
as some sliced pear which is pretty
interesting and then tops it off with
more cheese before sandwich in it all
together then she just goes ahead and
grills it in the pan making sure that
it's perfectly golden brown on both
sides and slice it in half and there you
have it Martha Stewart's grilled cheese
this one there's a lot of not
cheese-like ingredients inside there's
like that sweet jam and pear I'm gonna
give this a try and try to get both the
jam and the fruit in it's a little
different but it's not bad it's almost
like a sweet treat like a jammy sandwich
I also feel a little bit like I'm eating
a cheese plate
but in a bread you know when you have
like cheese and the fruits and the
crackers
it's just now in a form of grilled
cheese I don't know if I would call this
grilled cheese maybe I should have put
more cheese but this is what Martha said
to do this is definitely different
though I think from what most of us
would think grilled cheeses but it's not
bad
next up we have Chrissy Teigen she uses
two slices of sourdough bread and
spreads some softened butter on each
side then she arranges some sliced
jalapeno onto each slice making sure to
press down so they
stay there then she presses each side
down into some finely grated
parmigiano-reggiano cheese and she flips
them over and add some shredded extra
sharp cheddar cheese before closing it
up and dropping it in a pan once one
side is golden brown and extra crispy
she flips it over and repeats the same
process take it out of the pan slice it
up and boom there you have it
Christy Teegan is grilled cheese this
one smells so different from the other
ones because you smell the parmesan you
knows like Parmesan cheese crisps I feel
like you get that smell instead of the
butter lots of cheese in there to make
it fits a bite now it's still buttery we
feel like for this one is that part whoo
the jalapeno just hit me it is spicy
whoo I do like the heat that it gives
though it definitely like adds a kick to
it that you normally wouldn't expect and
I think if you like parmesan this is
definitely the grilled cheese for you
the texture wise I do feel like it has
that extra crisp maybe because of the
parmesan but mostly I think it's the
jalapenos that make this one stand out
would have never thought of this idea
pretty genius huh this next one is a fun
one by the game he starts off by putting
some takis and they mocha hits it and
smashes them up I didn't have that so I
just put them in a ziploc bag and crush
them with a rolling pin he also said to
shape the crushed chips into a heart so
I did that too then he dips each slice
of bread in sometimes making sure that
all of it is coated before dropping it
in the takis and covering the entire
slice of bread completely that's a lot
of takis then he puts some sliced
American cheese in between and
deep-fries the whole sandwich to get it
super crispy once it's done take it out
slice it up and that's it the game's
grilled cheese this is the one that
looks the most different it is bright
red I've never had takis before and yeah
I think the red is a little intimidating
it smells really good it smells like
carnival food but I think the
cross-section
looks pretty cool that coating of takis
really cool if you like because there's
so much flavor in the top keys it
definitely translates to this when we
kind of coat the bread with it I don't
really taste the cheese anymore mostly I
just taste the chips and the taste of
fried bread it's good and that kind of
like you probably can only eat this once
every month kind of way be very very
loaded but again I would say this is a
pretty creative idea so kudos to the
game for coming up with this idea pretty
cool
Antony is up next he uses brioche in
Ian's recipe and he starts off by
covering each slice with a lot of mayo
both for flavor and to make sure that
the cheese sticks then he adds some
grated extra sharp cheddar cheese a
slice of prosciutto and covers it all up
with summer cheese then he tosses that
into a very well buttered pan making
sure to press it down to help give it
that golden brown color and extra melts
of goodness flip it over do the same
thing again then remove it from the pan
slice it diagonally he insists in here
we have Anthony paurav skis grilled
cheese it looks very neat and tidy it's
like a little pocket so I'm gonna try
this bite mmm if you look for this one
the cheese didn't have that much time to
melt before the bread got a little too
Brown reowww should also just like
Stokes up butter a lot easier I think
I wish the cheese is a little more melty
and I think overall it has like a more
sweeter taste to it
brioche is just a type of sweeter bread
and it definitely comes out in this one
I like the prosciutto I don't think that
it's necessary but it's a good sandwich
but it's just I think not the crispy
grilled cheese sandwich that I would
normally like and last but not least we
have Kylie Jenner Kylie starts by
melting a very generous amount of butter
in the pan there she drops two slices of
sourdough in and adds a couple slices of
American cheese and seasoned up with
some salt and pepper for extra flavor
then she combines the two pieces making
sure that cheese gets gooey and starts
oozing out and then she slices it up
serves it up with some hot sauce and
some hot cheetos and that's kylie jenner
is grilled cheese I feel like this
grilled cheese looks like the most
common one that I
see this looks closest to probably why I
would make it home so I'm gonna give it
a try hmm I like that is very buttery
and crispy on the outside and I just got
like a hit of spice which i think is
from the hot sauce and I don't normally
put salt and pepper in my grilled cheese
but it's pretty good
also this is sourdough bread which i
think is perfect for a grilled cheese
because it's like chewy and it holds up
there's like some bite to it it doesn't
just like soaked up all the butter yep
this combination totally works after
trying all five of these celebrity
grilled cheese recipes I think my
favorite out of the five is actually
Kylie Jenner's grilled cheese recipe
it's so simple and so straightforward
it's like minimal ingredients but it has
that beautiful crisp on the outside and
uses sourdough bread it has that chew
there's a lot of flavor in the cheese
the salt and pepper was a nice touch I
don't normally do that but it does give
it a little bit more flavor and also the
hot sauce I like that it gave a little
bit of kick to it and obviously the hot
cheetos actually go together really well
and there you have it Kylie Jenner has
the best grilled cheese recipe what do
you think and also what other celebrity
recipes do you want us to test out next
let us know in the comments below and
we'll see you guys next time bye
[Music]
you